اذا قالت حركه حماس انها سلمت ردها بشان
اتفاق الاطار لكل من قطر ومصر وذلك بعد
انجاز التشاور القيادي في الحركه ومع
فصائل المقاومه واوضحت انها تعاملت مع
المقترح بروح ايجابيه بما يضمن وقف اطلاق
النار الشامل والتام وانهاء العدوان على
الشعب الفلسطيني وبما يتضمن الاغاثه بل
يضمن الاغاثه والايواء والاعمار ورفع
الحصار عن قطاع غزه وانجاز عمليه تبادل
للاسرى وقد ثمنت حماس دور مصر وقطر وكافه
الدول التي تسعى الى وقف العدوان الغاشم
على الشعب الفلسطيني وقالت الحركه انها
تحيي صمود الشعب الفلسطيني ومقاومته
الباسله خاصه في قطاع غزه وتؤكد انها وكل
القوى والفصائل الوطنيه ماضون في الدفاع
عن الشعب الفلسطيني على طريق انهاء
الاحتلال وانجاز حقوقه ال
المشروعه في ارضه
ومقدساته